le raisin n'est pas mûr mais les
vendangeurs sont déjà au travail c'est
la période des vendanges vertes le
moment où il faut aérer la vigne enlevé
quelques feuilles et surtout supprimer
quelques grappes pour permettre aux
autres de profiter davantage la véraison
est en marche et les grappes sont en
train de virer du verre au pourpre
encore quelques semaines de soleil et la
récolte pourra commencer c'est à ce
moment là seulement que le gros des
troupes sera à la tâche en attendant il
faut recruter c'est un peu différent
selon la taille des domaines chez moi
c'est un peu spécial parce que je suis
quand même un gros noyau qui revient
tous les ans chez moi c'est un petit
domaine donc c'est une ambiance
familiale mon beau-père fait la
charcuterie un bon casse-croûte ont fait
une bonne fête à la fin c'est des amis
et donc c'est une bonne ambiance tout le
monde attend ça avec impatience
vous êtes quand même sympa mais que faut
savoir faire le petit geste qui qui leur
fait plaisir faut pas avoir une cadence
à être derrière les pousser ils savent
moins connaisseurs le travail ils font
sens que j'ai besoin de me fâcher dans
les très grands domaines c'est devenu
plus compliqué le domaine faible et par
exemple doit recruter 300 vendangeurs il
faut étudier toutes les candidatures et
s'apercevoir que pour l'instant le
compte n'y est pas depuis deux trois
années les candidatures se font de plus
en plus rare et c'est vrai que nous
sommes obligés de diffuser un maximum
nos annonces pourquoi pour être vraiment
visible il faut je pense à tirer
les candidats domaine faible est nouveau
donjon entre 10 à 15 jours donc
forcément le salaire est vraiment
attractif voilà le paiement d'heures
supplémentaires fait que le salaire
reste très intéressant nous mettons
aussi en place des primes d'assiduité
pour les vendangeurs des primes panier
voilà des petits cadeaux voilà qui
change un petit peu chaque année et nous
offrons aussi du vin pour que les
vendangeurs puis ça prêt à goûter les
vins du domaine civil
les vendanges commenceront la première
semaine de septembre il reste encore le
mois d'août pour trouver de la main
d'oeuvre est peut-être convaincre les
indécis
juste le temps de laisser mûrir la
réflexion des candidats et le raisin